- Des forces spéciales hostiles
se sont introduites dans le port
de cette petite localité.
(coups de feu)
Des conscrits et réservistes ont
pour mission de les neutraliser.
Le scénario est fictif.
Policiers, militaires, civils :
depuis quelques années, l'armée
finlandaise organise au moinstoe
d'exercices dans les différentes
régions du pays. Une manière
d'être préparé à toute
éventualité. La guerre
en Ukraine n'a pas influencé
le programme cette année.
on reconnaît
que le contexte
est particulier.
On se trouve en ce moment
à environ 70 km de la Russie,
pays avec lequel la Finlande
partage une frontière de plus
de 1300 kilomètrrre
en Ukraine a ravivé le débat
sur la relation à entretenir
avec le voisin russe, mais aussi
avec l'Oalliance
militaire dont la Finlande
ne fait pas partie.
En 1939, le pays a été attaqué
par l'Union soviétique, qui
a subi d'importantes pertes...
Dans les décennies qui ont suivi
la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
la Finlande a voulu se tenir
à l'écart des rivalités entre
la Russie et l'Occident.
L'approche finlandaise :
collaborer sans adhérer
formellement à l'OTAN.
Une politique qui pourrait
radicalement changer.
Dans les rues d'Helsinki,
certains reconnaissent que
le contexte n'est plus
le même.
"Ils ont attaqué l'Ukraine,
l'Europe", dit cet homme.
Cette Finlandaise d'origine
russe, très critique du Kremline
si se joindre à l'alliance
militaire est l'option
la plus sécuritaire?
Surtout que la Russie
a récemment menacé la Finlande
et la Suède, qui n'est pas
non plus l'OTAN.
S'allier avec l'organisation
ne se fera pas sans conséquences
a averti le Kremlin.
ALEXANDER STUBB, prof, Inst.
européen, ancien PM de Finlande
- Il faut rester calme, il faut
être vraiment Finlandais parce
qu'on a maintenantent
vachement agressif, Vladimir
Poutine. On ne sait pas ce qu'il
va faire, il ne faut pas avoir
un autre clash, unonflit
ici en Finlande et en Suède.
- Cet ancien premier ministre,
favorable depuis longtemps
à une a l'OTAN, d l'OTAN, d l'Oe
aux dirigeants finlandais
de prendre leur temps.
Mais selon lui, la pression
populair finir
par avoir raison des réserves
des élus réfractaires.
- La situation de sécurité en
'est pour ça
qu'il faut avoir une analyse
de situation sécuritaire
et je crois que la population
ise a vraiment peur.
- Plus au nord,
loin des débats politiques,
on se concentre sur le bonent d.
Une mise à jour importante rés.
La Finlande n'est pas en
ce moment menacée de conflit,
mais il craint que son pays
paisible d'Europe du Nord
ne soit plus à l'abri.
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Aucl